nun ist es leider zeit für eine neue
folge unserer beliebten serie wie dumm
sind wir eigentlich wir vertrauen die
letzten die sich noch für unser
gemeinwesen engagieren
es ist leider so und wenn das so
weitergeht will hier in deutschland bald
keiner mehr kommunalpolitiker werden
haben sie wahrscheinlich auch gelesen
bürgermeister und gemeinderäte werden
immer häufiger opfer von körperlicher
und verbaler gewalt was einem da alleine
aus dem blöden internet entgegen
schwankt du bist hässlich sozial schwach
und stinkt ja gut das war jetzt eine
mail von meiner frau an mich aber das
prinzip ist das prinzip ist klar
geworden nach einer umfrage unter
bürgermeistern wurden in jeder zwölften
deutschen gemeindemitarbeiter und
amtsträger körperlich angegriffen
die zahl der gewaltattacken ist ein 2017
um 25 prozent gestiegen das wahnsinn und
das sind alles politiker ohne
personenschutz
immer mehr bürger sitzen offenbar dauer
wütender auf dem sofa und denken wenn
ihre kommune nicht exakt das macht was
in ihrer verwirrten birne gerade wichtig
ist dann ist das hier keine demokratie
mehr darüber was die sich aufregen des
screens das sage ich mal war eine
mieterin der gemeindewohnungen angerufen
hat und gesagt hat sie möchten termin
beim bürgermeister und im telefonat
kamen dann heraus die schuhe
verschwinden vor der haustür
die schuhe sind weg und der
bürgermeister macht nichts meine damen
und herren ja selber engagieren kommt
für die meisten leute immer weniger in
frage denn man ist ja voll damit
ausgelastet den ganzen tag wütend zu
sein wegen sachen ein mann ist mit einem
auto ins rathaus gefahren dann kippte
benzin auf die rücksitzbank und findet
den wagen an
neben seinem grundstück ist eine
tankstelle abgerissen wurden und dann
mehr familien ausgebaut wurden
und das hat ihn sehr geärgert natürlich
natürlich ja wer brettert einer ins
rathaus weil er um seine tankstelle
trauert wo leben wir eigentlich wirklich
wo leben wir eigentlich und natürlich
ist es bei attacken gegen politiker
völlig egal ob es fdp grüne oder die
af.de trifft so was zerstört das
fundament unserer demokratie
kommunalpolitik macht bald keinen spaß
mehr in deutschland das lernen schon die
kleinsten
bürgermeister du [ __ ] suchst du
streit tempo 30 gilt für alle benjamin
jetzt hör mal zu kollege okay ich nichts
zurück weiß ich ob ist elke dinge können
kaputt gehen
und jetzt macht dieser nazi fanden auch
den hitler gruß der muss weg so es
reicht benjamin du bist festgenommen
liegt ihnen weg nach thüringen
gutmenschen wie dort bilder assen fans
papis die spitze und scheint endlich den
anzug
ja
so ist das heute
kommunalpolitik viel spaß
die frage lautet natürlich was macht man
jetzt mehr solidaritäts demos von
bürgern für ihre bedrohten
kommunalpolitiker während zum beispiel
toll das hat in einigen gemeinden schon
richtig was gebracht die neuen gesetze
gegen hate speech die berlin
verabschiedet sind sicher gut gemeint
aber ihre anwendung rechnet der deutsche
richterbund mit achtung bis zu 150000
zusätzlichen verfahren pro jahr
viel spaß tatsache ist immer mehr
bürgermeister suchen vergeblich einen
nachfolger und bei vielen
gemeinderatssitzungen in deutschland
liegt der altersschnitt deutlich über
zdf meine damen und herren
und das geht eigentlich gar nicht über
zdf ein wahnsinn ja und weil so viel
nachwuchs sorgen kannst du eben leider
nicht mehr wählerisch sein wenn ein
neuer ortsvorsteher in deinem dorf
gesucht wird da muss sie zur not sogar
ein von der npd nehmen so wie neulich in
hessen die cdu im ort erklärt gegenüber
dem hessischen rundfunk dass der npd
mann der einzige jüngere kandidat sei er
kenne sich mit computern aus und keine e
mails verschicken
ja du hast mich aber
melles mail woher kommt die ganze wut
gegen menschen die sich engagieren
das betrifft ja nicht nur bürgermeister
oder kommunalpolitiker die wut gegen
feuerwehrleute amateur schiedsrichter
sanitäter ja auch sanitäter warum warum
allein 2018 gab es 700 reduziert
übergriffe auf rettungskräfte
aber zurück zur kommunalpolitik
vielleicht wäre es eine lösung dass die
bürgermeister die wir noch haben ihren
fehlenden nachwuchs selber ausbilden
sowie martin klempnow dein leben ist
viel zu ermöglich die menschen sind nett
zu dir
der fällt der check der fälle bereit
dann mach mit beim einem coaching ich
mach dich kommunalpolitiker
was hier ist der turm dem bildung aus
als meinen nachfolger hier darf nur in
meinem tutorial enzo alles aber sexy
themen wie abwasserentsorgung
grünschnitt verordnung
liegenschaftskataster oder sportstätten
nutzungsentgelte
kommunalpolitik das ist viel mehr als
blumen zum achtzigsten von oma hilde
auch zum 75 geburtstag von oma gisela
ist rhetorisch 1405 gibt dir die hölle
dosis dorfleben mit highlights wie
schützen testen
da kam es auch am samstag natürlich
wöchentliche konzerte vom frauenchor im
oktober
ich mach dich kommunalpolitiker punkt.de
verdorben wird hier gerade ein traum
wahr
lasst den traum auch für dich werden
dorfbürgermeister alle hassen dich und
du kriegst kein geld
hey du musst das jetzt hier machen ich
will dir heraus und bleibt doch dann
ging's los
so
aber es bleibt natürlich die zentrale
frage woher kommt die ganze wut woher
kommt die ganze rechthaberei meine
theorie ist ja seit jahren das hat mit
reizüberflutung zu tun also mit unserer
immer komplexeren globalisierten welt
das muss doch nicht so bleiben meint
till reiners meine damen und herren
[Applaus]
[Musik]
mit
nah sind sie auch überfordert fragen sie
sich es gibt so viele themen auf der
welt was habe ich nur für eine meinung
dazu
das muss doch einfacher geht s einfach
meinung grundsätzlich vermeiden also bei
sich anbahnende skus ion einfach sagen
neonazis das geschmackssache
überhaupt muss man zu viel nachdenken
vermeiden spiele der hersteller haben
das erkannt monopoly wird kein scheiß in
einer verkürzten version neu aufgelegt
das gefängnis wird abgeschafft und die
gemeinschafts felder und der hersteller
begründet das so wegen schulstress
handys und computern haben kinder nicht
mehr so viel zeit für brettspiele wie
früher
hier wird im neuen monopoly soll statt
bisher durchschnittlich drei stunden
nicht länger als 30 minuten dauern und
auch für scrabble wird es durch
schnellere version geben ich weiß nicht
wie die aussieht aber ich freue mich wie
ein schnitzel drauf mein vorschlag wäre
die buchstaben wegzulassen toll und
schon kann man was anderes machen es
gibt überhaupt viele dinge wo man das
ergebnis direkt vorweg nehmen kann
die deutsche durchschnitt erhält 14,7
jahre
warum so lange auf die scheidung warten
einfach mal das denken aus dem käfig der
logik befreien und menschen schätzen
damals erinnert euch mal an den anfang
also euer man kommt um auf die welt und
alle lieben ein mann schreit und packt
ein alle welt liegt ein
die metzgerin gibt eine scheibe kinder
mortadella auf die faust einfach nur
weil man gerade an der wursttheke
herumlungert und dann wird man älter und
klüger und sie klüger man wird desto
weniger menschen finden einen
niedriglohn noch heute vor der musterung
keine chance zu klug
deswegen gar nicht erst mit dem denken
anfangen und viele machen da instinktiv
schon alles richtig
ob da immer die richtigen klatschen
menschen sind ja komischerweise vor
allem schlecht darin menschlich zu sein
also angenommen
man schließt zwei menschen in einem raum
ein und sagt ihnen das hier ist nichts
vor ort da steht ein kuchen auf dem
tisch guckt wie er den unter euch auf
teilt dann kann es gut sein dass einer
der beiden sich denke wir könnten den
kuchen gleich aufteilen aber wenn wir
gar nicht nur die hälfte der hälfte es
weniger als alles und dann geht er hin
und ersticht den anderen mit der
kuchengabel das ist richtig arbeit mit
seiner kleinen gabel aber er will
einfach alles für sich und er machte
sich über den kuchen her schaufelten in
sich hinein und merck nach der hälfte
bot das schaffe ich nie mehr
ich glaube das ist kapitalismus es geht
also
es gibt zwei geschwindigkeiten der
entwicklung so die technische
entwicklung ist viel schneller als die
soziale komisch also alle können sich
auf den satz des pythagoras einigen aber
nicht auf frieden
warum funktioniert technische
entwicklung nicht wie soziale bei
technische entwicklung sagt manja guck
mal der satz des pythagoras funktioniert
wie geil ist das denn
endlich kann ich irgendwas berechnungen
drei irgendwie recht und genau so können
wir doch sagen guck mal frieden ist doch
für alle geiler als krieg lass es doch
jetzt immer so machen aber frieden
manche einfach keinen bock weil sie den
ganzen kuchen haben wollen erwachsenen
muss man immer wie kindern von neuem
beibringen dass krieg falls nein pascal
nicht dem dominik mit der kuchengabel
ins auge stechen und guck mal wenn du
der dominik wärst würdest du dich auch
nicht über eine kuchengabel im auge
freuen
es wäre so schön wenn es wenigstens
umgekehrt wäre also alle einigen sich
auf frieden aber niemand auf den satz
des pythagoras
ich kann es mir gut vorstellen auf dem
mathematiker party wie ich rechtwinklige
dreiecke berechnen ist meine sache ich
find's ok klar es würde bestimmt mehr
hochhäuser einstürzen aber nicht aus
böser absicht
[Applaus]